so this here is my titanium iPhone 15
Pro that I've been using with no case
for 88 days or about 3 months now I want
to do more longer term reviews not that
3 months is a super long time to have a
phone but in the usual smartphone review
space at least for me it's one to two
weeks with a phone before I'm
summarizing everything from my
experience and putting it into a rview
and so the longer I use a phone the more
I'm able to actually uncover about it
especially about the way I use it so as
someone who carries two phones all the
time and the iPhone typically is in my
pocket for a long time I have a lot more
stuff for this iPhone so first things
first I haven't put my phone in a case
since the day I bought it sometimes I
regret this sometimes I don't uh it's
pretty rare that I actually drop my
phone and this one also hasn't yet been
dropped but it does show some pretty
normal signs of wear and tear but it's
nothing too concerning like I always I
always start to get some bigger Cuts
like this on my front display glass
glass because of my refusal to put on a
screen protector and these here aren't
any more or less than usual despite you
know the fancy ceramic Shield but I do
really like the switch to Titanium for
the the frame and the side rails around
this phone it looks way better than the
stainless steel it's also lighter and I
am also glad I went with this lighter
color because this combo seems to show
the fewest fingerprints it looks the
cleanest overall though I feel like I'm
I'm happy with this spec that I went
with now long-term Behavior there are
three really interesting things about
this phone two of them I feel like I'm
using way less than I thought I would
and one of them I'm using basically
exactly as much as I thought I would so
first of all in the camera of the pro
iPhone uh this was the first year Apple
announced this sort of neat multiple
focal lengths feature so you can hit
that 1 x button three different times
and get three different focal lengths 24
mm then 28 mm then 35 mm focal lengths
all with the same quality I pretty much
never use this feature I don't know if
that means I'm like not a true
smartphone photographer but I just I
always just frame things at 1X and that
seems to be the end of it for me so I
just don't use that feature even though
our testing does show that it works but
I still think the new button they added
to iOS 17 where if you zoom in on a
photo a crop button appears and that
actually crops the photo that's
significantly more useful of a feature
for me and I actually think for a lot of
other people but then the action button
is another one so this is a pretty big
headlining feature on this year's Pro
iPhones this rare ability to actually
customize something on your iPhone so I
definitely feel like the UI that they
built into the settings is still one of
the weirdest most unle like stapled in
pieces of UI I've ever seen them do but
hey it works it's great you can map the
button to basically almost anything you
want but a lot of people made a great
observation about the placement of this
button when the phone first launched
which is like the reason that mute
switch that we used to have was so great
is because it was sort of tucked up in
the corner and out of the way so you
could just never even think about it
just leave your phone on mute for
forever and be fine but Apple was very
stubborn about placing this action
button in the exact same spot where the
meat switch used to be which does mean
it's kind of out of the way it's a
little bit annoyingly not very reachable
especially when you use the phone with
one hand so when I first got the phone I
mean I was going nuts with all the
possibilities of the crazy things that I
could think of to do with it first thing
I did was map it to Google Assistant
since I never used Siri but having a
quick toggle to the better assistant is
hilarious and more useful to me then I
later briefly switched it to toggle
starting a new voice conversation with
chat GPT so the Chad GPT chatbot has its
own voice and you can have a voice
conversation with it and it's really
cool but it isn't the most useful thing
in the world like it's cool that it can
do complex math and reasoning and
generate new things for you but then it
can't see your calendar or tell you the
weather or do anything current events
related so that didn't last long so then
I switched to uh starting a new dialogue
box for a new task in my to-do list app
of choice tick tick and this one's
pretty cool you hit the button and it
literally opens a text box and you just
start typing a new task really really
nice if you just happen to remember
something somewhere but I also totally
still have the muscle memory to just go
home and open the app whenever I need it
I also have a lock screen task to do
that so it was a little bit redundant
for me so I've ended up with my action
button just being set to open the camera
and that's the fastest most convenient
way to get to the camera for me yes
there is a lock screen shortcut also but
I just find that if I'm doing something
and I just need to quickly get a picture
of something that's happening or or I
just something's about to go away I
don't want to miss it like I just have
this muscle memory now to just hit that
button and just take the photo you can
actually have it open to take a selfie
or take some other types of photos or
videos I just have it open the
viewfinder and I'm good so then of
course USB type-c was the biggest
headlining feature of this newest
generation of iPhones hilariously enough
slow USB 2.0 speeds on the bass iPhone
15 but then USB 3.2 speeds on the 15 pro
and pro Max which makes a pretty big
difference when importing tons of prores
footage even if it isn't Thunderbolt
speeds yet first of all thank you Europe
it's about damn time uh even as someone
who is a pretty heavy wireless charger
user I do have to say it is much nicer
it's been great to just have one cable
to charge almost everything from this
iPhone to any Android phone to the iPad
Pro to my laptop but unfortunately I
have not been able to get rid of my
lightning cable just yet because there
are still other things in my ecosystem
in Apple's ecosystem that haven't
switched to USBC quite yet mostly
because airpods Max is my headphones for
traveling of choice and I still have to
carry the lightning cable everywhere
just to charge those but there's also
still the magic keyboard and the Apple
Magic trackpad I really don't know how
long it's going to take apple to go
through and also update all of these
things to be USB type-c but but I guess
my lightning cables are sticking around
a little while longer until they refresh
all that stuff the airpods max came out
at the end of 2020 so word on the street
is they may be due for a refresh
sometime soon but we don't know
definitely get subscribed to see the
review of the new ones whenever they do
come out but as of right now they're
still lightning so there have been
several software updates to the iPhone
15 lineup since it came out it launched
on iOS 17 which made all the types of
headlines but then we've already made it
to iOS
17.2 the new journal app is live now
with which I have a few friends that use
but I don't use it there's of course
been a bunch of bug fixes and
optimizations since we heard about you
know the Instagram app and those random
heat problems those seem to also be
fixed and gone and there's also a
curious new little button in the camera
app so if you go to settings and then
camera and then under formats there's a
new toggle to be able to record spatial
video for the Apple Vision Pro so things
seem to be lining up interestingly for
the Vision Pro to actually launch
sometime in January or February which
should be pretty cool and if you
remember watching that one demo of
spatial videos on the Vision Pro yes you
can record them on the headset which
looks hilarious but you can also record
them on an iPhone specifically only on
an iPhone 15 or 15 Pro so far because of
the horizontal alignment of the main and
ultrawide cameras so if you go into the
camera app with that new check toggled
in video there's a little headset icon
and if I select that I'm now shooting
that special space faal video which
means a few things first of all you must
turn your iPhone sideways to landscape
because your eyes are next to each other
not on top of each other and it also
will limit you to 1080p 30 FPS because
it's actually processing two streams of
video at once one from the primary
camera that you can see but then the
other one from the ultrawide camera for
your other eye so you can go crazy right
now and just go out and start shooting a
bunch of spatial videos on your iPhone
but if you go watch them on your phone
they will look just like normal videos
because it's only going to play back the
video from the main main camera if you
want to see and appreciate the spatial
of the video you will need an apple
Vision Pro now I've actually gotten to
experience the Apple Vision Pro a few
more times since that initial preview
video that I did from Apple Park Flex I
know but what I've actually gotten to do
with it is shoot a bunch of my own
spatial videos and then watch them back
on the headset and the main thing I
really learned is they look okay I think
the the dramatic part is like when you
get the subject within 2 3 4T of the
camera then it's like really dramatic
kind of like a 3D movie then you see
things popping out at you so Pro tip if
you're going to take a bunch of spatial
videos now that's the sweet spot for it
to actually be worth it oh and also
another Pro tip it took me months to
learn this but if you ever have anything
happening on the dynamic Island you can
swipe across it to hide it or change the
view style in case you're annoyed by
like a a train ticket or an Uber
delivery that's taking up space up there
or something you just don't want to see
up there anymore so go ahead and swipe
the more you know so clearly you don't
have to upgrade your phone every year or
every two years or very often at all uh
but the more I use this phone 15 Pro the
more I'm confident that this is one of
the good years to upgrade from the
updated cameras to the USB type-c to the
titanium like there's there's a concept
of an upgrade sweet spot and I feel like
this phone hit it especially for people
with much older iPhones so I'll leave
you with this in the original iPhone 15
Pro review I compared this phone to the
Porche
911 uh in that the design doesn't really
change a whole lot from generation to
generation they instead spend a really
long time refining and honing in on a
slightly better version of the same
thing so I just turned 30 recently still
weird saying that out loud but for my
30th birthday I decided to take that
plunge too yes it is Matt black but I
can now say that once you start living
with a 911 you actually appreciate that
strategy just a little bit more it is
not flashy it's not dramatic it's boring
it's predictable it's familiar
confidence inspiring also this entire
video every single shot was shot on an
iPhone 15 Pro thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one
peace